new research shows Americans living in
Colorado Virginia and Arizona take the
most vacation time from work the
advocacy group says group project time
off found people in those states are
taking more than the national average of
around 17 days off
residents of Montana Delaware and Rhode
Island take the least time off John
Tierney is are contributing science
columnist for The New York Times he's
been researching how science can help
you make the most of your vacation John
great to have you on the show we've been
talking about this all morning is a
little happy science you call it our
bosses are listening something very
clearly you say taking vacation is good
for your health
yes science is very clear is that you
know people who take more vacations
they've fewer heart attacks they suffer
less from depression they're actually
more productive at work to you know say
it's good for your body because it
reduces your stress hormones it puts
your immune system and it's really good
for your mind because doing new things
stimulates dopamine activity in your
brain and that gives you more optimism
and more and rich total sense to me
what's the ideal length of the vacation
probably more short vacations rather
than one long one because what is short
your definition of short I mean I think
a week is good you could even do shorter
than that but and one of the big
advantages of vacations is that it's the
anticipation beforehand makes you happy
the one or twenty beforehand so the more
you can do that the better and what's
the day that you're happiest on vacation
is there any science on that yeah when
they study people who take longer
vacations they find that happiness peaks
on the eighth on the eighth day so you
know maybe go for eight days and then do
it again and how about the coming back
John because sometimes people say I need
a vacation that might be thank you
depressing yeah right it's hard coming
back so build in a buffer I'm you don't
go straight from the airport to your
work I think and I think one of the best
things you can do when you come back
from the vacation there's that
inevitable letdown you know start
planning the next one right away well we
usually go down on us come back on a
Saturday so that's planning right away I
think because the planning makes you
happier you know it's you know
psychologists find that you know to be
happier you're better off spending money
and buying new experiences rather than
buying
thing yeah did you anticipate it more
and you've got those memories afterwards
and you can relive last longer John the
things last longer
well they last longer but they don't
bring you the same kind of pleasure you
know that I mean when you do new things
it stimulates his dopamine in your brain
and that's that gives you more optimism
that gives you more energy and it's and
it's the same brain system that gets
activated when you fall in love so it's
a nice way to reignite a romance it's a
great way to build any kind of
relationship really so do the Europeans
have it wrong when I lived in Europe we
take you know the month of August off
and we would say I'm only starting to
get my vacation on two weeks into it is
that not the way to do it I think it's
better taking more you know frequent
ones but I mean however you do it
basically do what you enjoy think I mean
it's nice to get away someplace new it's
nice to do new things but if you're the
kind of person that gets stressed out by
that you know go into the same place
every year is fine too I mean it's your
vacation do whatever makes you have so
we shouldn't feel guilty asking our
bosses more time off you should tell
them you the people who take more
vacations as we get more raises and more
promotions that really work yeah i'ma
tell them God said so what do you like
to go John no I'd like to go someplace
new I was just out in the West and you
know and I also like to do something
with my family but we usually go to a
new place every year we have a family
reunion okay we're going next week I'm
very happy anticipation all right we
wish you a good vacation John Tierney
thank you very much